today on couch tomatoes we're talking
all things Emmys tell you one thing if
you lose it certainly won't be for lack
of touching people into Denny's hello
everybody what's up everyone I'm a
surprise and welcome to the brand-new
show from Ryan tomatoes couch tomato is
brought to you by for sheddeth here's
the thing with TV and all these new
streaming services it's so hard to
choose what to watch on TV because
there's so many good options out there
which is why you're on couch tomatoes
we're gonna help you guys out and we're
actually kicking off our first episode
talking all things Emmys because the
Emmys are this Sunday and lucky for me
I'm not doing this alone joining me on
the couch today is senior editor at TV
Guide malkov Venable fandango's film and
TV correspondent Nicki Novak and Indy
wires Ben Travers hello guys I feel like
I have the Golden State Warriors of the
like you guys watch so much television I
can't wait to hear predictions before we
get into predictions so I really want to
talk about the big stories that
everyone's talking about when it comes
to Emmys starting with Game of Thrones
right I mean a whopping 32 Emmy
nominations they already sold 10 of them
this past weekend at the creative arts
Emmys however they had a controversial
last season right 58% on the tomato
meter I think the series average is 89%
on the tomato meter a lot of people feel
like the final season was rushed we saw
caramel macchiatos on set I wanna start
off with you do you feel like this final
season is gonna take Game of Thrones as
legacy or do you feel like the Emmy
voters are actually gonna honor Game of
Thrones I think it's both I think the
final season kind of tainted its own
legacy but in terms of the Emmys they're
gonna give it all the awards still there
they're so locked in at this point
because there's just not a lot of strong
competition out there like the other
shows are great but they're not as
beloved they're not as instilled within
the Academy as Game of Thrones so
they're still gonna make a run on Sunday
and it's it's gonna be a lot of wins
there were a lot of shows that also
wouldn't qualify this season like
Westworld we didn't see Handmaid's Tale
a lot of shows and the crown that we
would normally see go up against them
and I think that's part of the reason we
saw more nominations yeah there's still
nothing like it on television to have to
scope and scale and production and story
they feel like Emmy voters tend to favor
final seasons I think they do when it's
the right kind of timing I guess like
you've seen it happen
with stuff like Breaking Bad like they
got really really excited for those
final that final season slash to split
seasons of Breaking Bad and they really
wanted to give it as many awards as they
possibly could despite a lot of intense
competition out there but madmen final
season was widely ignored Jon Hamm was
able to pull off a win because he just
hadn't done it yet but they felt like
they'd honored it so many times already
that they were kind of done with it I
feel like now that it's been a couple of
months since the last episode in
people's madness has sort of cooled off
a bit you know is the writers that
people are mad at primarily not
necessarily the actors and I think we're
that's where you're gonna see I'm even
hearing were like the words sweep this
week that there could be a sweep of a
game of Thrones so I think people are
sort of getting behind it again and sort
of want to see I mean it was a cultural
phenomenon I mean you're not gonna see
anything like it for a long time if ever
thank heaven all these people don't know
their names
watching football yeah under the helmets
but what's interesting about the final
season of Game of Thrones and you were
mentioning madness is that when HBO was
getting a lot of flack for this final
season true noble kind of came up out of
nowhere and was this instant success for
HBO and it got me thinking about the
next big story of Emmys that everyone's
talking about which is Lead Actor in a
limited series where Jared Harris from
Chernobyl is actually nominated but when
I look at this category it's really
insane you guys we have all these Oscar
winners Benicio del Toro ma Hirsch la
Lee Sam Rockwell all up for their first
Emmy ever but really the buzz is around
Terrell Jerome and Jared Harris so
Malcolm I want to hear from you first do
these two stand a chance against these
seasoned actors absolutely but I think
it's gonna go to jor-el I mean he's he's
just 21 which is remarkable and he did
such a phenomenal job in when they see
us but I think there was specific things
that work in his favor from that
performance the story is timely it's
about social justice he was the only
person in the cast to play a younger
version of the same person right and
then he had an entire episode to himself
where he was in solitary confinement and
he just really kind of broke out of the
confines of what should we even expect
to see on television it was just
fantastic if he doesn't win
I'm frightened Oh put that out the end
of it I'm putting it out there that's
somebody with the letter J is gonna win
no I think it's between the two and I
don't even though we have legends I
think it's social relevance and Buzz and
and Chernobyl and when they see us have
that so between the two I keep going
this is one of my toughest categories
when we get to the predictions I still
don't know what I'm going to say it's
going to be either Jared or jor-el you
know in terms of the Oscar winners out
there I really think Michonne only is
the leader of that squadron of folks
like I think he delivered such
incredible performance unsure detective
but at the same time I feel like you
know we've we've given it to Marshall
before he won two Oscars right like he's
very well known and very respected I
think it's probably time to share the
wealth a little bit and I think people
are really excited especially given how
many nominations when they see us has in
the acting categories to award somebody
from that case man yeah and I think a
couple years ago if film actor did a TV
show we kind of assumed they were going
to win the Emmy and I don't think we're
necessarily seeing that anymore right
which is crazy yeah you brought up
something that got me thinking between
jor-el and Jared because I'm also torn
between these two there's this kind of
generational struggle here you know do
you ward someone who's been at it for a
while who gave us a standout performance
or do you award the person with this
breakthrough performance so early on in
his acting career
I saw it gives it as an opportunity to
be for lack of a better word hipper and
cooler because there I was a kid not
even 22 yet but Jared Harris I will
argue he is sort of an unsung hero he
has been around for so long and hasn't
necessarily got the accolades as someone
like the bigger stars in this category
emanated for Mad Men and a lot of people
were actually upset that he wasn't
nominated for first season of AMC's the
terror so yeah so I think it would be
one of those things where if he did win
I don't think anybody would be
necessarily mad at that because he does
have that body work and hasn't been sort
of a name like he's always been in so
many things and he's that person that's
just not a big star but he's deserving
and weirdly enough it feels like you
mentioned he's broken out on TV already
like he's had enough rolls through Mad
Men through the tear through the crown
where it's like he should have been
recognized more than he has been with
the Emmys which makes me think that
they're just not as big of fans perhaps
as the rest of the world or less at
least the rest of the TV community well
one person they're not slow for is
missed
Julia Louie Dreyfus I mean next to the
word Emmy winner in the dictionary I
feel like it's her face but before we
get to Julia Nicki and I actually sat
down earlier to talk about all the
must-haves you need for an awards worthy
watch party check it out all right guys
so aside from hooking you up with all
our predictions we're also gonna tell
you how to spice up your award show
watch party this weekend I'm actually
having one of my plays I need a little
help with this what do you think that I
should serve okay so whenever I have a
party I always serve pizza because you
can't go wrong with pizza it makes the
party if somebody doesn't like pizza I
don't like them yeah no I agree and when
I throw a party my go-to is for shut up
because they have so many different
flavors they're just made better and
this rising crust pepperoni is always a
hit it looks amazing yeah people are
obsessed with this set for that so now
I'm thinking pairings I know red wine
always goes well with pizza but what do
you think like champagne cocktails I
think it's fun to switch it up I think
people forget that Pizza goes so well
with so many different drink pairings my
personal favorite pizza with champagne
is actually this brick-oven spinach and
mushroom diving in there's something
about the earthiness of the mushroom
that just goes so well with the rich
fruitiness of the champagne when I'm
throwing a party I always like to
elevate the experience and I throw a
little gin lemon and sugar in the
champagne it's called a French 75 and
that is also always ahead we're so fancy
you really have to come to my party my
joy my day oh my god Thanks you're
serving for shutting champagne I'm there
yay cheers Cheers okay let's talk about
Julia Louie Dreyfus I feel like she has
more gold statues in her house in the
city of Dubai she could soon hold the
most Emmys for a performer of all time
she's currently tied with Cloris
Leachman for 8 Nicky does anyone stand a
chance against Julia in the lead actress
for a comedy series I think this is the
biggest lock of everything at the Emmys
but it's so much of a lot it's reminding
me of Glenn Close at the Oscars how
everybody thought she was gonna win and
then there was a shock when Olivia
Colman won so that's the only thing I
think barring a shocking moment like
that I think she's a lock I think she's
been a superstar through this whole
thing I think if they're gonna award the
show sort of for their last season it
might not necessarily go to veep but
Julia will be the person that's going to
win yeah and I mean I think over the
last few years when veep was a sure
thing in a lot of categories that it
felt even more like Julia was just you
know she was
take it like you just wrote that off you
didn't worry about it but because it's a
little bit weaker this year because more
other comedies have more nominations
than HBO's you know crown jewel maybe
this is the year where Julia finally
slips off maybe this is the time when
Phoebe Walbridge sneaks in for a fleabag
or natasha Lyonne sneaks in for Russian
doll
both of those got some creative arts
Emmy love this past weekend which was
really exciting so you know it could
happen I'm still with you I still think
Julia's got it but I'm a little more
nervous than normal
well you know I say when it comes to the
Emmys it's like you know Jan Brady it's
like Julia Julia Julia as far as the
it's hers
I mean does Brosnahan have a chance here
she did one last year when Julia you
know wasn't eligible if it was a should
win category I would choose Rachel
because I think she continues to excel
on that show but I think that show will
clean up and I don't necessarily like
fourth or fifth bills Julia in terms of
what you can about Catherine O'Hara -
because even talking about and this
would be her aware seconds it's like 9
ths and once it's like 1982 or something
like that
and she's such a beloved character not
that other ones aren't but I mean
Mauro's he's an iconic TV character I'm
shocked that more people aren't talking
about I think people are though I think
in terms of an upset that name is
getting bounced around as much as
Phoebe's name is and I think that's
another person that if she were to win
people would jump to their feet
absolutely huge Julia my hitter outs
leader in the park
want to take a second and talk about
first-time nominees and some fresh faces
who are some first-time nominees that
you think people should be paying
attention to I'm team Darrell Jerome
again we know him from its outstanding
turn in moonlight which seems like
ancient history and to think he's is
young care for the monks who actually
never even thought that he'd be able to
become an actor
I mean so many boxes get checked here
he's fantastic for representation of
Latin ex and african-american performers
this story is like timely relevant
socially conscious the material that he
had to work with was obviously
outstanding I concur but I'm gonna throw
in an Anthony Kerrigan I absolutely love
him on Barry it is one of my favorite
shows
but that character NoHo Hank he's such a
standout every time he comes on screen
as much as I love the other actors he
steals every scene he's in and I think
he's pretty much a long shot in terms of
a win but I'm so glad he was nominated
and he's making like no eyebrows like
look fabulous I've had that before it's
the alien look is not good I'm waiting
for the eyebrows mine is Jodi comer for
killing Eve whoo I just feel like is on
fire right now like you're just kind of
waiting with bated breath to see what
else she's going to get to do because
she's so good on killing Eve and
creating an assassin in 2019 who's
unique and stands out and the people
want to keep watching and are interested
in and doesn't kind of just fit the the
mold of previous characters she's done
that and then so much more I'm just
throwing out there she should be a
Marvel superhero I think she would make
a great that is such a she's new she's
fresh she's a great actress and she has
a presence as far as fresh faces for me
I'm really into Joey King right now like
what she did in the act the physical
transformation just shaving her head I
feel like she gave us such a deep and
mature performance and we're so used to
seeing her and like these kid and teen
friendly movies like the kissing booth
on Netflix and just the video that she
uploaded on social media when she got
nominated like actually made me cry I'm
really excited for her that she's
nominated and I just can't wait to see
what she does that reminds me of like a
Natalie Portman like how she was a young
actress that you just knew was gonna be
a massive actress when she got older and
she's that person yeah okay guys so I
feel like we got through all the big
stories we got through all the
first-time nominees that we think you
guys should watch out for but now I want
to go through each major category and
know who your predictions are because I
have a car payment to pay off and I'm
going to be making some bets this
weekend so I want to hear who you guys
predict to win and then after you guys
tell me I'm actually gonna tell you guys
what the RT staff pic is and so these
are the expert predictions for the
nominees on TVs biggest night based on
the combined ballots
the editorial team here at Rotten
Tomatoes so first one lead actress in a
comedy series we obviously talked about
this when we talked about Julia but I
want to know down the line who do you
guys think is gonna win this weekend
Julia Julia Julia Julia Julia Julia
she's like Tom Brady had a super boy
she's just a shoo-in and surprise
surprise guys the RT staff pick is also
Julia louis-dreyfus so I will be shocked
if she doesn't win this Sunday I think
she will - okay so lead actor in a
comedy series when I look at this
category I think there's a lot of
showbiz legends in this category you got
Ted Danson Michael Douglas Eugene Levy
and then you have Bill Hader who's
nominated again won this category last
year so who do you guys predict to win
Billy Gunn though again really good bill
haters gonna win this he's the it guy
the it movie and it he is the it guy of
the season yeah yeah they're not they're
not done rewarding Bill Hader just yet
he's gonna win yeah okay well the RT
staff pick also thinks it's Bill Hader
so hopefully he takes that
okay so Outstanding Comedy Series and I
want to make note that no show that's
one for its first season has ever one
for its final season because I feel like
a lot of people are looking at V right
cuz it's the final season so who do you
guys predict win Outstanding Comedy on
Sunday I think veep is gonna win
although I like fleabag to win people
win all right I disagree I don't think
it's gonna be beep I think veep only has
I think eight total nominations I think
the marvelous mrs. Mazal I sort of
flying under the radar just because we
kind of go okay we've heard it we've
heard it but I really think that 20
nominations are impressive but I think
marvelous mrs. Maysles gonna win I was
actually team Barry up until the
creative arts awards and then after
Mazal just kind of dominated that scene
in a way that we didn't expect I'm
starting to come on to the Mazal side
and officially I'm gonna go maybe I just
win you over yeah Artie stop it guys is
fleabag and I also think fleabags gonna
be okay and I think Levi's gonna do not
set thank you for validating me okay
let's move on to lead actress in a
limited series this category is very
interesting right Patricia Arquette won
the globe for escape at Dannemora but
this time Michelle Williams is in the
mix who do you guys have winning lead
actress in a limited series I say
Michelle Williams
this is a phenomenal performance and on
top of that I think the story that is
sort of rent engines of the actual show
has been great so I think mr. Holmes is
the winner Nikki I have nothing more to
add so I concur about Michelle Williams
but I need to give a shout-out to Amy
Adams she will not win but she was so
outstanding in sharp objects it's gonna
be Michelle she's got so much love
around town like the the response that
people have shown her for the during the
fyc screenings during her kind of
campaigning around town it's been
overwhelming and I think she's gonna dig
it I think she's so deserving of it too
and the RT staff pick agrees Michelle
Williams for Fosse verdun okay Lead
Actor in a limited series we kind of
talked about this at the top of the show
we didn't really talk about Hugh Grant
too much like it was therefore a very
English scandal and then kind of just
went away who do you guys predict to win
this category this Sunday it's ro
Giles Rome this is the toughest one for
me but I'm going with jor-el I'm going
with jor-el as well I I feel like he's
he's captured the momentum at this point
and also I'm they love that show it
would be so epic to see him when to over
all these seasoned actors in the
category but the RT staff pick actually
thinks it's gonna go to Jared Harris and
we're noble don't also be happy to see
him take it okay let's talk about
outstanding limited series we kind of
talked about this at the top of the show
when I look at this category all of
these shows are based on real-life
events except for sharp objects and I
feel like the race here is really
between Chernobyl and when they see us
both powerful stories that portray you
know these great and justices it came
out of willful ignorance who do you guys
predict to win this Sunday I say when
they see us you know we've talked about
the social justice aspect that's also
really well done this was a trickiest
one for me it was so so tough it's so
neck-and-neck and I really had when they
see us but with the creative arts Emmys
Chernobyl's sort of just upped the ante
a little bit I think it has the slight
edge right now but it could go either
way I'd be happy with either but I think
it's gonna be Chernobyl I actually agree
with you in the sense that I think
Chernobyl has the edge right now but I'm
sticking with when they see us so Niki
the RT static actually agrees with you
and they're going with Chernobyl so this
will be a really fun category to watch
on Sunday okay moving on to Lead Actress
in a Drama Series this category has a
staggering seven nominees Ben you kind
of talked about this at the top of the
show I feel like the race here is
between Sandra oh and Jodi for the same
show
so who do you guys predict Sandra Sandra
I like Jody better this season but she
didn't win before and this is a historic
moment for her and for you know women of
Asian descent as well that's the thing
that's gonna carry her necessarily but
um she just still did a phenomenal job
so I'm going with Sandra I'm actually
gonna go outside of the box a little bit
I'm gonna go with Emilia Clarke I think
it's gonna be a surprise there for Game
of Thrones I think she's so beloved I
think you know she's been nominated
before several times and I think this
app me this is the last chance for her
to get this this win so I think it's
gonna be hurt if that's the win that's
the one I'll riot for so while you're
writing very angry Familia wins
especially because San Diego you're just
so oh well it's interesting because the
RT staff pick also thinks it's Sandra
but Sandra's also never wanted any mercy
okay let's move on to Lead Actor in a
Drama Series this category is really
interesting because Billy Porter is the
only first-time nominee yet I'm hearing
a lot of buzz about him what do you guys
predict
yeah it's Billy Porter and he deserves
it and I think it's been so great to see
his sort of campaigning for it and the
way he talks about having been
overlooked as a performer for most of
his career now to be in a position where
he's the lead I think people love it and
have great feelings about the show and
him so I'd say Billy's the winner what
do you think I agree I think it's
Billy's I think Billy is by far the
front-runner in this category yeah I
think it's a little bit closer than that
I do think the Jason Bateman has a shot
for Ozark but I am gonna go with Billy
Porter I think I think pose has that
slight action and guys surprise surprise
the RT staff pick is also for Billy
Porter for pose so I really hope we see
him win this for Sunday moving on to the
big one Outstanding Drama Series do we
still think it's gonna be G ot yeah yeah
it's definitely gamer zones if you want
to get your new car that's gonna be the
one yet yeah again your odds are gonna
be terrible whatever would bet the car
on Game of Thrones I think if there's an
upset lurking which there isn't it would
be succession if only because it's
gained so much buzz for the second
season and people have really kind of
picked up on it a little bit late and
maybe enough people like
HBO wants to see it hit but it's not
gonna right it's still gonna begin with
rose okay and the Archie sapphic also
agrees that it's gonna be Game of
Thrones so guys thank you so much for
all your predictions hopefully we got
all of you guys back at home setup so
you're ready to go on Sunday but before
we go I want to talk to you guys about
what your fresh picks are so these are
shows that are nominated for an Emmy but
maybe are a little bit under the radar
so what show do you think everyone
should add to their watch list
that's a Twilight Zone Kumail Nanjiani
is nominated for his performance in the
first episode of the new CBS take a CBS
all access take on the series and he
plays his stand-up comedian who's in
this like warped demented universe where
he has the ability to make people die
with his with his routine I thought it
was fantastic I want to have that
ability my pick you just mentioned
succession a minute into it I was hooked
on the show but if people for whatever
reason haven't stuck with it episode 5
is when it really kicks in and it goes
and it goes to another level do you
agree with you and also season two the
most highly addictive show if you want
to get less sleep watch that show no my
fresh pick is actually big mouth on
Netflix a new season is just around the
corner it was nominated for Best
Animated program it's co-created by Nick
Kroll as well as a slew of other people
it's got a great voice cast Maya Rudolph
absolutely owns the whole thing she pops
up in just the most amazing ways in the
way she says bubble bath you will never
forget I'm going with Fosse verdun
because I love Broadway you guys but I
never knew the behind the scenes stories
of Bob Fosse and Gwen Verdon we talked
about Michelle Williams she is so unreal
in this I was watching the episodes and
I was like can someone get a Tony Award
for a theatrical performance on screen
like asking for Michelle Williams it is
just so good
FX series produced by lin-manuel miranda
and I feel like a lot of people didn't
watch it I think it came out right
before season 8 of Game of Thrones so I
feel like it got lost in the shuffle
with all the amazing limited series but
I just love love love fussy worded
alright guys well that's our show that's
all the time we have for today I want to
think
guys so much I feel like we covered so
much ground when it comes to Emmys if
you guys want to see a full list of
predictions from Ron Tomatoes head on
over to Ron tomatoes com also let us
know in the comments section what your
thoughts and what your predictions are
if you agree or disagree with us we
really want to hear from you guys and
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell it is free
and you won't miss any future episodes
of couch tomatoes thank you so much for
tuning in to the first episode the next
one we're doing is American Horror Story
1984 I am so excited
thank you to malcolm nikki event for
joining me today guys i'm not surprised
and we'll see you guys next time
Cheers Julia Julia
[Laughter]
[Music]